according to sources YouTube are buying  twitch for more than 1 billion dollars  and Google's world domination continues  variety reported on the news citing  sources familiar with the pact thing  that the deal to acquire the platform  twitch has been made by YouTube which is  PR director said on Twitter that which  doesn't comment on rumors and Google is  yet to make an official statement but  the word is that a proper investment is  set to come through shortly the report  from variety indicated that Google is  getting ready for us regulators to  challenge the acquisition because since  YouTube is already the most popular  internet video platform as it stands it  should be seen as anti-competitive for  them to a quiet which let me know if you  reckon this one will prove true and what  you think about Google buying twitch in  that commenting section down below we'll  have all the information as it unfolds  right here on gamespot  you